what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from comedians dressed as Santa
did you come all the way from the North
Pole I got to be honest I thought I was
going to be able to handle this bit to
learning holiday history with Joe Rogan
they are like the shiny packages
underneath the Christmas tree they are
the color of Santa Claus they're common
in Siberia they're eaten constantly by
Caribou Caribou are reindeer these are
the best Christmas moments starting off
with a bad friend secret santa o secret
santa I didn't bring a gift what do you
mean what for secret santa I had to give
put a we all brought a gift for secret
santa what are you doing we agreed to do
Secret Santa didn't you bring a gift no
one told me about George you never told
me about secret santa we picked the
names last week what do you mean we
picked names live on the air I have
proof what did you get one yeah yeah
what are you talking about you we we
just picked the names we just did it
I never I hope I'm not Bob I I never got
a gift George thank you I forgot what
even name I got Andre I got your gift oh
awesome come here this is for Andre it's
under here where is it let me see it is
this this is
yours so you got a gift from me I never
saw you bring anything to the [__]
car no but I um delivered it to George's
house so that you won't see it wait a
minute wait are you lying I'm not no we
all got gifts why didn't you who who's
yours I don't even remember Bobby who's
yours I swear to God I don't remember
Bobby who's yours I swear to God I don't
well I'm giving a gift to
Andre thank you yeah and Rudy's got one
for you yeah and then George yeah so who
do you think yours is yours and what did
you get me Merry
Christmas you didn't get me a secret s I
forgot I just tot forgot toally forgot I
forgot and then you get a gift yeah
before I open it what is it open it no
tell me what it is I know what it is
tell me what it is cuz we I don't want
to say it yeah say it tell me what it is
chicken hot pies chicken pot pies
chicken hot
pie chicken pot pie oh you got it from
uh belly yeah congratulations that's
really nice cool
you're so you're so
annoying oh my God you got really
upet George make sure the are those
Frozen No no no it's still frozen
they're Frozen Frozen all right I'm
sorry I forgot I forgot about I if I
would have remembered I would have got
you something great we pulled the names
literally like some me I don't know [__]
I don't know what's going on who did you
pull I think it was you you know it was
me I don't remember how you going to
handle Christmas presents for each other
for Tom and me yeah we don't do that
[__] you don't well I mean I got you
like some stuff here's the here's the
what I figured out over the years it's
like hey let's not do gifts so this and
that and then you're like that means you
probably won't get me
something I'll I'm still obligated to
get you something so that you don't feel
like God you didn't get me anything I
mean I know we said we weren't going to
but I didn't think you were that's why
I'm asking cuz we're in that POS she
clearly said that but can I tell you why
anything I bu my husband he'll be like
oh
thanks what it's gone yeah but here's is
that because you're a bad Gift Giver or
because he's thank you yes thanks for
saying it
garbage let's what are we supposed to
get him a Rolex every time I don't know
what do you want you have everything
I'll say this that's the problem you
don't really need anything you don't
need anything also so some people are
just more skilled in this I am a really
good Gift Giver I really am I and I've
always been a good gift giver and I
enjoy it I enjoy the whole process and I
remember like it was a few years into
dating her I was like hey do you think
on I finally was like you think on this
upcoming Christmas you could not give me
some [__] and she was like what do
you want and I was like I don't know
like a [__] iPad or something cool
and and then I think I went out and got
it I was like give me this you to buy it
yourself yeah why do you have such a
hard time with it it's just not at your
whe you know why it's not okay I think
it goes because my parents were like
such communist like they literally
escaped communism so my upbringing was
stuff is not as important stuff is like
she gave me ground beef when I
was not give you ground meat she's like
it's good meat it's good meat
one time we got robbed Christmas Eve my
dad got me a new bike with a bow on it
got robbed the Bow's aren't going to
help no and then uh my dad was like
mother you know Christmas was ruined and
we saw the kids riding by on my bike on
Christmas morning with the bow on it oh
God and boy talk about just like insult
to injury you like like oh these kids
aren't even fearful that they'll get in
trouble or you know anything will happen
oh it was it was heartbreaking you know
I've had I've had those kind of days
those kind of
holidays you know where you know where
some hotti watch it let you you know let
you watch your breastfeed a little not
for a long time just enough you know
where you play that song
um Hallelujah just one play you know cuz
it's almost biblical you watch
that you watch a baby getting tited out
and you listening a hallelu you know
where uh
oh bless ye Mary gentl there's something
very Christmasy about it
slushie
beheading
churro death that's what they want so
with
that we we wish you merry merry holidays
Merry Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah if
you're celebrating
Hanukkah OJ Simpson that was great not a
Jew Paul Newman correct half yeah Cody
Hans have Jewish Paul Newman's have two
there it is put them together with a
fine looking Jew that was a that that
it's a great song song changed the game
it's I'll put it up against any
Christmas song easy that's all we have
easy there
Sandler listen winter solstice
saturnalia was celebrated by gambling
drinking having sex running around
playing games playing music what does
that sound like today sounds like
Christmas Eve in my house genuinely
sounds like Christmas Eve in my house
and then somebody gets punch in the face
and thrown
out what's up uncle Todd would Christmas
be fun without the Christmas tree which
there's not a reasonable explanation for
I guess some Germans started lugging
trees in St Nick who was just some Greek
dude thank you for the editorial
retractions in the comments from last
episode he's some Greek Bishop does he
sound like a fun guy was going to buy
you a toy no he was a bishop right but
what did we do we made it fun we lied
about it we said Santa Claus is St Nick
we changed him into Santa Claus we made
him we made him a fat Scandinavian dude
who flies in the sky with reindeers who
can fly and delivers presents like
[__] Jeff
Bezos okay through your chimney for
children and eats your cookies and
bounces a little bit of milk and it's
gone what's funner
what is funner getting kissed under the
mistletoe or sitting around praying
being thankful for baby Jesus and
fasting which one's funner which one
should we which one created the reality
we believed enough in San right we we
started wearing Santa Claus hats
nobody's wearing a Jesus cross and
having a great time nobody's wearing St
Nicholas St Nicholas's Bishop robe who
you know no family's going like which
which adult is going to dress up like
the real St Nick for the kids to make it
fun no they're dressing up as an
imaginary guy named Santa
Claus that we made up and that is a
complete lie here's the deal December
25th wasn't even Jesus's birthday they
changed it they took some Winter
holidays from the roogan Roman pagans
and they plugged it in and they said hey
let's move it to December they probably
went like Hey Man Winter's dreary unless
you're in New Zealand and then it's just
dreary CU you're in New Zealand so let's
just do something let's spruce up up the
winter a little bit and make the Big
Dog's birthday go in December it's all
[__] but it's better and coniferous
trees would grow these weird looking
shiny red and white mushrooms under them
that's what coniferous trees is pine
trees that's what we use for Christmas
trees those red and white packages they
they are like the shiny packages
underneath the Christmas tree they are
the color of Santa Claus yeah they're
common in Siberia they're eaten
constantly by Caribou Caribou are
reindeer reindeer are addicted to these
to the point where when people are
having psychedelic mushroom rituals and
they go outside to take a leak the
Caribou will knock them over to get to
the ammonita muscaria piss in the sand
cuz they smell the ammonita mascaria in
the piss cinnamon Christmas we you know
what we did today we went out and bought
the tree bu a tree oh we got a tree we
got a tree last week now so you have an
idea the price of these trees I haggled
I mean it's like the guy slid four
fingers in this way and four this way
and just opened it up and shoved a
couple [__] in there yeah the old Vice
anal now you're in Manhattan so I don't
even want to hear the numbers we don't
have trees on the island so they got to
ship them in from Bosnia or whatever cuz
I'm paying I'm paying International
prices my came from According to this
fella came from Quebec 14-hour car ride
what ridiculous it a migrant from santis
I showed up with 40 bucks and eight
bucks to tip just in case and uh I had
to go back to my house I'll tell you
that
bones Christmas tree I'm not cleaning
that Christmas tree what 120 bucks what'
you pay it's natural it's from the earth
I know but the drive 14-hour drive from
Quebec I can go to Staten Island and
chop down a a pine for free what' you
pay I paid 60 for a mini ah the 60 mini
I got the Brad Williams over here and uh
it it's a tiny little tree I tried to
put the uh the lights on it and it went
I know the branches hung it's not easy I
mean first of all the funnest part is
they pull it through that little that
thing oh love the dick uh dick glove
there they pull it through there and
then I felt like the guy recognized me
cuz he really was looking but he didn't
say anything yeah yeah yeah so you feel
you got to really be gregarious sure and
then I had a a guy I know come and do a
stoping chat and I'm like I'm buying a
tree that he's like hey what's up man I
was like ah nothing just buying a tree
feels like When Harry Met Sally and he's
like that's a good film but I feel like
it's a little bit of a Woody I'm like my
wife's buying the tree I can't leave her
alone what are we breaking down nor
Efron here come on Efron you uh Enron so
I shove him off we get the tree he said
the price I mean I'm not kidding
that's crazy it's it's a natural thing
it's like imagine telling that to a
Native American Buck 20 and I said who
man when I was a kid a tree was 40 bucks
and he goes but how much was gas then
the old what's good for the goose is
good for the cander what does that mean
oh gas gone it means is everything's
gone up so everything's more expensive
and then he gave me the Quebec story
again aay what a what a Canuck I love
you sha Claus all
right right sh did you come all the way
from the North Pole I got to be honest I
thought I was going to be able to handle
this
bit but how old are you dude I usually
only listen to like Stern or jazz in the
car I don't listen to radio that's my
whole life but when the holiday season
comes 1067 or the or the holiday
channels on serus just thr it boom right
my opinion Christmas all day 2our drive
Christmas ins sync Merry Christmas and
uh uh Mary Mariah carry Merry Christmas
song in my opinion two best yeah I sinks
one which is Merry
Christmas Happy
holid
Christmas I did a Christmas shoot a
Christmas thing where it looked like
Rudolph was sucking my dick where I
where you could just see the red glow I
was just like oh [__] and it was just
like the red glow was just bouncing off
my tits and I think that got me taken
off taken off the first time that do it
yeah you guys have been asking for joke
World merch for a long time now and I'm
happy to announce it's finally here we
got hoodies we got hats we got t-shirts
we got flags and we got coffee cups and
from now until Christmas we will be
donating one item of food to feeding
America for every merch item purchased
so if you want to support the channel
while helping out those in need check
the link in the description below now
back to the video this comic uh Mike
Sone he was headlining there and he
asked me to do like a guest spot on his
uh like holiday Christmas show cuz he
knew I was in town visiting family
and uh one of the comics that was on
there um later on uh he first degree
murdered his girlfriend first degree
first degree wow uh and my brother when
he saw that he sent me the article he
goes I bought that guy's DVD after the
show well I love Christmas with all my
heart I know a lot of people that can't
stand it for all the planning and the
stress traditional dinner
Christmas traditional Confections and
treats there's drinks uh Christmas
drinks things that associated with hot
cocoa uh Feast of The Seven Fishes
things that you bake around Christmas
you going in narrow with the Feast of
The Seven Fishes I love the Fe you know
what I'm saying a b a big Italian a big
dinner no matter who you are you're
having a big big dinner that doesn't
happen with birthdays I love big dinners
I love sitting around breaking bed bread
with family and friends I Love Thinking
of people wrapping their gifts and then
I get to pay off if I buy 20 people
gifts it pays off 20 times I get them to
open the gift I got see their reaction I
love that Santa Claus who is the
birthday equivalent of Santa Claus
yourself no I'll tell no you buying
something for your friend CU I'll tell
you I'll tell you there's nothing more
rewarding on somebody's birthday on a
friend's birthday when you because
you're not competing
with piles of gifts you're competing
with about six maybe seven 10 other
people and when you get the standout
gift in that group that feels great man
in Christmas no on your on somebody's
birthday the stand oh when you have
given the stand out gift because you get
a far less amount of gifts on your
birthday when you give somebody at the
party the standout gift and you're like
I hit the home run this year but there
are St do there are radio stations that
stop their programming to only play
Christmas music it's the only holiday
with a legitimate full genre of music
you have
legitimized musicians that do Christmas
albums you have you decorate the house
we put trees
indoors by the way the Christmas light
my favorite thing in the world hanging
light I think Christmas light should be
on homes and businesses what about
streamers and balloons what about
streamers and balloons it's a bit much
oh please I can handle it once in a
while that's crazy all right we got to
go to the phones we got to go to the
phones we have to go to the phon you can
celebrate Christmas on the eve and the
morning
you could celebrate Christmas adult
style and then in the morning you
celebrate a kid style you know I mean I
there's Christmas the movies your
child your child's first birthday your
child's 10th birthday your child's 16th
birthday your there's a lot come on we
go your parents your parents 60th
birthday your your your parents 75th
birthday okay I ask you this you could
celebrate Christmas every year from now
on we got to go to the phone or your
birthday every year from now on and not
Christmas what do you choose birthday
I choose Christmas all right well enjoy
that as time continues to mean nothing
and you're robbed of all holidays
because you're not allowed to go outside
anymore all right I'm I'm seeing a lot
of people writing that their birthday is
on Christmas what do you guys think of
that oh I think he got robbed that's a
real bummer so then that Christmas
they're really suspicious I couldn't
tell you when this was but you'll see
the footage and they're like we want to
get footage of Santa I just gotten a
GoPro and and and they were like can we
I see the girls on the DL set the GoPro
up on the
mantle by the way this gets really bad
what so they're going to bust you so how
do you oh sh so but they're [__]
idiots they they don't even charge the
GoPro they don't have an external
battery they don't even put a [__]
128 GB card in it they didn't even check
the card see if there was anything on it
CHS are [__] stupid just put it up
there they're two mouth breathing NES
and they just hit record like it like
that's going to get them I go hold on
guys yeah what are you guys doing and
they're like on the DL they're like
nothing and I go you guys trying to
catch Santa and they're like we just
want to see if it's you and Mom I go
okay I said well put it up there but
listen if you're going to do that let's
get an external battery so it can run
all night and they're like okay I'm
going let's get a big card so we can
record all night and they're like so
wait you're really not Santa and I was
like no I I'll put it up there and if
you guys check the footage and if
presents show up they show up whatever
so I put it up there I record right I
leave it we all we have a few cocktails
the girls go to bed I go to bed I wake
up at 2: in the morning and I walk in
dogs are laying on the couch this is I
will send you the footage I will send
you the footage this perfect Priscilla's
on the couch I walk in she lifts her
head up puts her head exactly down in
the same place I walk over to the
[__] walk over to the mantle I get
underneath the mantle I have bells with
me and I have a white Mitten and a
flashlight I get underneath the mantle I
jump down so the bells ring right I
flashlight around Priscilla sees a
flashlight looks flash right to Mona
then I look and I to the flashlight up
to the GoPro then I take the white
Mitten very like the white Mitten and I
grab the grpro I turn it around I turn
it around and then I jingle all around
and start messing with presents and then
I go about my way I got go off and I do
my thing right but I leave it in there
so smart Christmas dinner we're over at
my sister's and I'm with my dad and my
mom and the girls go Dad upload the
GoPro V footage let's see if we got
Santa and I was like guys I can
guarantee you Santa's magic he's
definitely not going to get caught in
this video and they're like Dad just
upload it my dad's like what happened I
go these idiots put a GoPro up to see if
they could catch Santa my dad's like oh
I think they're going to be surprised at
who they caught and I was like yeah so I
put the footage in and it rolls it rolls
for three hour you know from when they
put it down three hours it's three hours
of footage and I go guys you got nothing
you got absolutely nothing and then Isa
like a detective goes scroll to the end
so I scroll to the very end and the
camera is in a different spot they're
like the camera's in a different spot
and I go oh my God we got to scroll and
find the place where it moved I scroll
back I find it and what I had done is I
had spliced me walking out seamlessly I
had cut it out and I had just married
the two together and I scroll and all
you see is Darkness Darkness Darkness
jingle jingle flashlight glove flip
around and for some reason I don't know
why but when I move the flashlight
around I mean the it proves there is a
Lord in this world
the flashlight made a shadow that looked
like an elf and the girls were like it's
an elf oh my God even my dad's like you
got a video of Santa and I'm like and
I'm looking at my dad he's like he they
get up and he's like how the [__] did
you do that and I go Dad I just edited
the video and he looks at me he goes oh
buddy you're [__] your kids up really
I said really and he goes That's not
healthy man that's really not healthy I
cuz I in my opinion you just created
like an ideal childhood like I If my dad
had done that for me I would have felt
so loved Santa Claus what did you think
about the uh jokes of Hans Kim here
tonight I liked him I actually don't go
to China a lot to drop off uh presents
it's a long story but I don't go to
China anymore they don't have Christmas
in China anymore I don't know if yall
knew that it's a new thing yeah it's a
brand new thing this year there's no
Christmas in China whoa I refused to go
to China after the debacle last year
with that old virus thing it was a
nightmare in the [__] Igloo with all
the toys and the little
dwarves God they were all sick yeah I'm
not going to China this year it's
incredible the Olympics are pulling out
the Diplomatic committee pulled out
today and Santa Claus Santa Claus yeah
I'm not [__] going there you can't
make me go to China okay let's keep
moving along here uh to Mexico wow and
get a ton of stuff at dutyfree and come
back yeah you're just you know how much
you know how much awful hello yes it's
Jordan yes you're going to die uhhuh
okay I'll put you through to someone who
gives a [__]
put your Christmas tree up yet I did I
put it
up the Tuesday before Thanksgiving wow
How You Like Me Now real fake fake aroo
I had a uh seven years ago when I moved
into my where I moved in I had a real
one and it was a lot of H and then I
went to Costco and I picked up this
pre-lit 9-footer things like butter man
dude I had it seven seven years now I
take it out I put it up you put the pole
inside the other pole it's like four
pole four Parts all the lights are
already on it lights up boom you get
colored lights or white lights and it
falls into shape my when we were younger
do you remember shaping the tree yes
stepping back it's bad enough that you
have to go step back well not bad enough
it's part of it should be part of the
fun and put the the stuff on equally but
the shaping of the tree was was was also
a thing see I was see this is why you
don't you you got to just communicate
with friends because I was going to
sheepishly and embarrassingly and kind
of in a forgiving tone in an asking for
forgiveness tone tell you that for the
first time in my life for me and my
family we got a pre-lit tree and I want
to tell you that I'm sorry that maybe
you know that's you don't condone that
behavior and that's not right and I'm
taking the spirit of Christmas away but
my kids don't mind it they like it they
had fun putting it up and all I have to
do is press a button and it goes on and
off and it has made my life so much
simpler where it would one now we have
that tree in perpetuity we can close it
put it in a box put it in the basement
and I don't and they will is a tree in a
box Tree in a box
girl the my kids each have five
Christmas ornaments that they love and
they put each one of them up and it's
all good you streamline it bro I'm
streamlined the the prel tree is it's a
game changer you got to call it for what
it is does it take away from a little
bit of the tradition and the process of
that yes do I mind not particularly
these days my time is limited and so
anything can give me a step ahead I'm
all for the convenience if I had more
time would I want to be more of a purist
possibly got it does that give you
really any answer either way no no all
right here we go uhhuh TW the night
before
toy as read by H Foley okay T the night
before Christmas and all through Toy's
Place The Joint was jumping the music
was pumping you could hear it from space
Toy's crew were getting together to
spread a little Christmas cheer but we
knew there'd be trouble later when they
ran out of beer me and the Fellas were
chilling up in our room just minding our
Biz T-Bone was working on the computer
Kippy three man's haton deep Luke was
taking a whiz I just hooked up my CPAP
and was ready to snooze when I felt hot
breath on my cheek which red of heaters
and booze and toty's face was an inch
from my head she said that fat piece of
[__] is up on my roof with those rain
reindeer and sled I said what's with the
insults he got beef with Old St Nick she
said he ghosted me last Christmas after
I sucked on his whoa whoa
whoa I said why the hell are you telling
me this she said because I want you four
idiots to help me steal a sleigh and
really put his panties in a Twist now I
knew stealing Santa's whip would Dam ass
all to hell but when we got there oh boy
what a story We Tell Kippy and T-Bone
came up with the plan will steal his
keys then lock him in the can as the
Clock Struck midnight we made for the
roof but first rubbed our balls on the
cookies just as a
goof toty took around to the shoulder as
Santa went for his
gun yeah things elevated quickly I
thought we were
done but by some miracle of God we made
it to the sleigh all safe and all sound
Tippy slammed on the G assas to get us
off the ground and as we climbed through
the sky we heard the old man shout I'll
get you punks if it's the last thing I
do the geizer cried out but we were long
gone out for a little Christmas Cruise
probably stopped by Sev grab Bernie a
lighter cheit and booze what a perfect
way to end an amazing year in this
holiday season stealing Santa Claus's
ride for no goddamn reason toty was
smiling from ear into ear she whispered
to me Foley I think this is going to be
our year and I heard her exclaim as we
drove out of sight sign up for the live
stream it's New Year's Day
[Laughter]
[Music]
night at joke
world and it world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out